I. Whether or not.
Johnny jelly easily won
a double early in. Job.
I'm johnny allen i was the co-director
of the nieman aquarius festival in 73
and by dint of my role as director of the
australian new students a since then i've
pursued a pretty chequered career leading
to my current role as events manager for
the downing harbor thoroughly
responsible for all of the activities
that happen in the outdoor
spaces of darling harbour.
Yes. Niman in the
aquarius festival for me.
Came out of the series
of strands of things
that i'd been involved in i mean one
fairly important one was the other.
And one may wonder at first how cedar
can accept with him and what nimbin was
but for me as i say my early
training was in theatre
but i soon sort of became interested in
theatre in the wider sense if you like the
other in the streets as theatre
in environment as the other and
that led me into doing a series of
smaller events sorry and around sydney
that were festivals but in the context
of going out to a country like asians
and exploring the australian environment
for me it was a little bit about
that it was as a young australian
that had been born in the country
and moved into the city.
It was partly about
rediscovering country australia
and rediscovering the environment and
then with it all of the questions
that were being thrown up by environmental
damage and environmental pollution.
So theatre was. One
significant strand of it.
Another one was what i would
call the university culture.
I think that i was a student at
the university new south wales
and i think the universities around
australia at that point in time.
I'm talking now the mid to late sixties
were an area of somewhat interesting
ferment and ideas and
you know fertile ground
when i think back to many of my contemporaries
at university where they've gone
since it was an interesting time.
So part of it was that sort of
university culture and as i say.
In the chemical side of an embed for
me was it was a job as director of the
aquarius foundation which is something
that the australian you know students had
set up to try and encourage cultural.
Circuit around the universities.
So in the in the year as a leading up to
nimbin one part of my job was organising
tours of everyone from jenny
lewis to eddie cool through to
various environmental speakers.
Ron cobb the cartoonist phil oakes
the original sort of folk musician
a whole series of things designed
and where possible we took
that in the direction of
not just entertainment.
But in the direction of cultural tourism.
I guess you call it all cultural
entrepeneur me so that was one direction.
The other was of course. Rock music.
I had in the years immediately
prior to nimbin i'd been running.
One of sydney's only two rock venues called
the art factory which is down in golden
street and that wiped out the factory
was in those days was a bit of a home
and a breeding ground for alternative
australian music i mean many of the bands of
the day that were drug etc..
Had their home in the arts factory
and probably if it weren't for the factory
they would never have existed and
that you know some of those been.
Full. I like when a guy etc.
Went on from reasonable obscurity
to be fairly mainstream figures.
So for me a lot of it was was this
business of running a music venue and one
that was very much about generating an
australian rock scene because it's hard to
imagine now unless you live through it
and can take your mind back to australia
with the sixties it's hard to remember
just how how american straightening culture
was in those days you didn't listen to
you know too much australian music you
listen to american music when you watch t.v.
You watched american t.v..
So part of
that process for me was trying to give birth
to you know genuinely australian john
or rock music which now seems
one when one wonders now how
that can ever have been an issue
that it was an issue in in the 60s
and then i guess the other strand was.
What i recall in those days is as
being called the counterculture which
is a phrase that people don't use anymore
but that there was a sense in sydney
and i think quite a tradition
going back to the 30s
and 40s out of an
underbelly of the culture
that was was a little bit more adventurous
radical imaginative than the mainstream
culture and there's a very
definite feeling in the city
that as i say went back to the wonderful
characters of the 30s all of the the
leader vines in the bee miles.
There was a feeling of a radical
tradition and i was very interested in
that both both in terms of. Arts culture.
And perhaps less so politics and there
was a whole john were there for me
that niman represented a
bringing together of a theme
and then i guess the final one was what's
become known now as as the alternative.
Turned of scene or the. The
new age movement or whatever.
Those are terms that i think arrived a bit
later but there was also a sense that.
That we were in some sort of crisis.
Yes i mean those days we talked about holes
in there is only if people thought you
little bit mad
but you know they were we were
talking about those sort of things
when we consider seriously worried
by them and it seemed to me
and to many other people that
i work with at that time
that we were in a pretty radical situation
and we had to investigate
some radical alternatives.
So i mean what an embed threw up was
just one of many possible directions
and i don't think we were
conceited enough that to say
that you know this was the
direction but it did seem that
that an ace we explored some you know
some pretty radical new departures in the
ideas that we were probably stuck on a one
way trip that was heading for a cliff.
So i guess all of those thoughts
came together as a background that
that led me into dropping out of a you
know fairly tailored career is an a.b.c.
Producer
and into this somewhat less favorable
territory of a cultural entrepeneur
and director of hippie festival.
Ones always in those things ones always
attracted by a range of things some of
which is sort of petty in. And.
In terms of my own involvement
in various things.
It's looking back on it's a little bit
hard to discern the motivating forces some
of that i think stand a fairly small and
petty things like you like the people
and i'm a very clearly
when i grew up in a fairly
conservative australian household
and quickly figured out
that the sort of people who were involved
in things like the were in the arts were
more interesting than the sort of people
that i'd been raised with so i naturally
gravitated to those sort of people and
that means hanging around the craft
or going you exploring various things
that was
that was the place to be so some of the
weather is sort of more lurid motives.
I think they're
intellectual and so i think
that australia was coming out of a
conservative post-war period. I grew up in.
Through the 50s with sort
of acres of the forties
and straight he was a very
sort of grey suited short back
and sides sort of society.
It didn't pay to be very different
and you paid a price for it.
So i think some of it was you know just
they were able instinct i guess of
and i think also there was a as
part of the post-war baby boom
and i really think that at that
point in time not just myself
but a lot of my contemporaries really felt
that we were in a position to change
things and change things we did.
With for better or worse is now open to
question but there was a feeling that
that you know that you
could actually step in.
And you could actually be powerful enough
in situations to change the course of
events and. And then
change the directions.
So that's i think what it
what attracted me that that
that intellectual side
of it and the challenge
and the comradery of being
with like minded people and
that you know they were
they were good times.
I suppose young generations
always find the good times
but a lot of it was made in your hair
down just making the most of times
that would be aired.
When we started.
Evolving a festival
and a program for nimbin i mean i
guess one of the first tenants was
that what we didn't want to do we were
reacting against a nine hundred seventy one.
Aquarius festival that had been held
on the the a new campus in canberra.
When if they were acting against it was
actually a very good very enjoyable
festival but it stayed very
much in a traditional now
and it was about dance companies
on stage in the air to come.
These in theatres and music in halls
and i think very early in the piece we
decided that in terms of the energy
that we wanted to put into a festival
for that for the time in the place that
that kind of festival really wasn't going
to be what we wanted what we were looking
for something which was much more able
to to explore wire to wire styles
and wider questions so culturally i
set out to shine network which is a
word that. I don't think i
used until pepsis after that.
In my role as cultural director i was
constantly travelling i'd be in perth on
monday in adelaide on wednesday
and you know back to back to
melbourne on saturday in sydney
and then there again
and graeme used to travel quite a
bit to gram dunstan like a director
and what we would often
do was say arrive in.
In adelaide for a weekend
and we'd say ok let's take a fine
books who is there in this town
that we think is actually
an interesting thinker
and do whether they run a
health food restaurant
or whether they run an
alternative newspaper
or whether they've got an interesting
theatre group doesn't matter
and we would constantly
throw these dinner parties.
I don't quite know how we
manage the food and the cooking
but 40 people would
come along with explain
that we were you know
trying to do this gathering
that was very much about exploring new
turn into new cultures usually quite a lot
of people would that would get up
and sort of say ah you know you know you're
still living in the sixties man then
she realised things to you know this
doesn't happen anymore and we would leave
and then of the 40 people they'd be
five people sitting there saying
when do we start. Sounds great.
What we do next
and say are slowly we accumulated this
sort of you know some hundreds of people
around the country who were
interested in the thing
and interested to the point of stopping
everything else in their lives
and making a total commitment and
culturally i was interested in following
that through to you know who were the people
who were the instigators whether they
were the musicians who were genuinely
creating a strange honor of music
or whether they were.
The people who were thinking
passed the other in in four walls.
So there was quiet a network there
and that was both a national network
and an international network.
It was national because we were drawing
off a university circuit today
that would be pretty
limited. But in those days
that university circuit had inroads into
the cultures of most of the australian
cities pretty deeply so that there
were few thousand people ultimately
that were part of
that great find probably did represent an
interesting thing take of of people in
australia and then there was an
international network which was looser.
Which would simply come about by every
time i heard of some interesting
organisation or performer overseas
that seemed in tune with nimbin
i would write them a letter.
And sort of this massive bank of
goes by and it's basically again.
Simply saying what we're
doing in inviting them over
and then sort of you know talking to funding
bodies like the australia council it's
a to see what assistance
we could line up so and
that was all very much on a basis of what
i guess i would call tribal cultures
whether they were people coming from.
Tribal cultures such as africa and india
that were literally still living.
Semi tribal lifestyle
or whether it was the urban tribes of the
philly parties of the labor from paris.
There were you know we're
just part of this.
Global counterculture
but we gradually attracted quite a few
people some of whom we actually managed to
organize air tickets or fares for
and sort of you know came semi officially
others who just had heard about it in a
bar in berlin and sort of
thought it sounded interesting
and they were at a bit of a loose end so
they started making their way to australia
so
that was actually quite an interesting till
gummidge i mean in the three months leading
up to nimbin they would have been
left 3 3 500 people living up there
and working around the
clock on building toilets.
You know organising food chains etc.
With no idea of how many people were
going to turn up to the festival in may.
I mean it could have been.
Sort of you know a couple of thousand it
could have been 50 thousand nobody really
knew because no one was
enrolling in advance
or sending you know the same thing in their
interest which made the australian new
students rather nervous i
must add i think graham
and i would say there's the madman the
public going to destroy the union forever
and every time we turn around there be
another knife in the back so to speak
but it did give rise to this sort of.
I mean my guess is that
something something between 10
and 15000 people finally came through nimbin
we did manage to you know to organize
the food the food chains
in the first aid etc.
Say that nobody starve nobody died and
it was a fairly interesting gathering
and one where i think
what was unique about it.
And what came out of
that whole process as i think everyone
approached it not so much in terms of where
paying a gate family coming to
a festival to be entertained.
Everyone approached at the other way
around. We're coming to make it happen.
We kept saying there's
no program the program.
What are you going to do and
people came with that attitude.
I mean the remarkable way
and some people whom we've had long
communication with another have never heard of.
I mean this sort of entire
kind of you know 10
or 12 piece theatre group from new
zealand called blurter turned up in this
wonderful bus that was the real sort of
magical mystery tour and just turned up
and said we're here. You know we're
here where we perform where you like.
So lots of people came in that
sort of spirit and very much.
I mean i remember of using using
phrases like you know what you eat
and whatever the whole the whole line was
that this is a festival it's about culture
in the wider sense it's not about just
bands on stage is it's about the art
of how you create your living space.
It's about the art of how you cook
a meal it's about all of that city
and so it was a very
remarkable campsite as all.
Say they hows nz of people camped
outside the small isolated estate in
country town with some of the
weirdest and most wonderful.
Structures
and performances they were people in tree
houses there they were people is sort of
that they had a lab rat domes there were
people who'd sort of carved out sort of
holes in the ground people into a
piece almost anything imaginable
and i mean part of the joy of the thing i
think was was wondering around through
this bit of a magical mystery
land of all of these things
and just encountering you
really did have the feeling
that she didn't need to go to the stage
to be entertained whole thing was an
entertainment and the fact
that there were some people in there who
i mean you know an interesting example i
think is phillipe pati who we've
heard about on the grapevine
and managed to organise affair
from the australia council lisa.
I think is the blunden
of this this generation.
He was the most extraordinary man in
terms of balance and physical feats
that i've ever met.
So he came to lehman with no fee with an
airfare a year later he was paid a million
dollars to walk between the twin towers
of the financial district in new york
and
when the festival sydney tried to invite
him back to australia for the bicentenary
in 1988 they couldn't afford him.
So there were you know
there were people of
that caliber people who you know on a world
level i think are remarkable figures
and then you know many people who give up
and give a wonderful performances never
heard of before and never would again.
All of which i think was manifesting a
little bit the spirit at the festival which
said that sort of you know
really were all artists.
I mean we live in a society that
makes special things about it
and it in some people in
the multimillionaires
but basically you know
will artists and somewhere
or another in the true artist life.
Wouldn't i wouldn't mind talking about one
more performer. It's it's that again.
Let's go. Another another i think
very interesting performer that
that we invited
and it was again part of this networking
process was an amazing african musician
called dollar brand and the mechanism
by which dollar arrived at him
and i think was interesting because it says
something about this networking process
through all these dinner
parties in different cities
that i mentioned earlier we ventured sort
of cumulated quite a large number of
people who weren't on the payroll and
had no title but it was just understood
that what they were doing was working
full time but then investable
and one of these was a very interesting
south african called bastogne who
knew african culture fairly well
and knew australian alternative
culture fairly well
and he was determined to being what he felt
was the most significant musical figure.
Of his country which is a brand.
We did actually again managed to get some
assistance eventually from the australia
council for his fares and he was a person
that just it was the most wonderful blend
i think of traditional african music
and modern jazz in fact he spent his
divided his life between swaziland.
And the manger jess for
the years in europe.
And so again one one of those wonderful
examples of of someone who came to the
festival and came uniquely
in an in a unique way.
And there's just one more i'd like to touch
on i mean one could probably go on for
an hour listing the amazing performance
turned up at neiman but the one that
that i think for me was the one.
Stop the whole thing out most
magnificently was a group that. Arrived.
Very late in the festival in their
arrival was it was very special for me.
There was an incident. Halfway through
the festival where someone was.
Alleged to have been peddling hard drugs
into there was a story about rape
or whatever. All of which ultimately
turned out to be fiction.
I think spinning off the idea
that. Nimbin it had happened.
Very soon after the election of the
whitlam government coming to power in 73.
And 70 to say and in the seventy three.
And it's part of the whitlam government
coming to power it had been a pretty strong
coalition between the student movement
and the labor union movement.
And a low we weren't terribly aware of it.
I think there are a lot of forces
there that were interested in.
In nimbin being discredited not for
anything that had anything to do with us
and what we were doing really but because
of that larger political context.
So we could figure out this this supposed
drug insert was in fact a set up.
But what it resulted in was the 21st
quite coming up from sydney the whole of
nimbin sort of you know falling
into sort of two army camps.
Left the radicals on one side and and
the twenty first class got on the other
and then sort of a lot of lot of people
said sitting in the middle saying hang on
we must cool this out and
meditate our way through it
and whatever to the point
where it really took over.
I mean the whole festival
became about this incident
and it was blown out of all proportion.
And i didn't cut quite know what to do
about it at the time except to to proceed
with you know trying to bring the last of
these these marvelous guests which was a
group from from india called
the bowels of been goal
and the bales were quite unique in
that they are one of the oldest musical
traditions on earth they go back to
previous times in india
and what they traditionally were in been
garrulity been gaily countryside was the
deep seas the message being
is so even to this day
when the bowels arrive in a village
in india everyone dance to.
And as a great party you seldom even comes
to listen to the vowels because they
actually seen you the news of
the day and this is a tradition
that i gonna do you know
to thousands of years.
So we had got to the plate for i had the
most famous vowel rupe of the day sitting
in calcutta ready to come.
I managed to you know to raise the fares
for them to come but i had no visas
and getting them there and outside in
the fields there was this you know.
Really was at the point where it could
have flared into riots that he moment.
So i hopped on a plane went down to canberra.
I never met him before but sort of.
Knocked on the door and
and strode into to visit dr h c coombs who
was a rather remarkable gentleman who
had sort of set up the australian council
and been almost single handedly responsible
for post-war reconstruction in
australia after the war and that
states was head of the reserve bank
and a very powerful
and influential man in in canberra so
walked into his office he sitting up there
with this huge absolutely
clean mahogany desk
and on on the table in the new i was but
that was all on the desk in front of a bee
had the the local afternoon rag at the
headline that read something
like sort of you know.
Ten thousand students riot police beaten
and was is absolutely sensational
it's piece of gutter press on.
So you just just looked
at me looked at the paper
and said i know who you
are what do you want.
And i started to burble out that i've got
these six people sitting at calcutta
and i'm and i'm trying.
They just picked up the phone
to immigration said coombs here
and they said you visas if you read in
that an hour. So i went back on here.
Plane back then but managed
to get these people into.
In vibe is bin and down to
nimbin by that by the next day
and coincidentally they are i have
that the neiman festival at
the height of the full moon
and at the height of all this.
And drama that had been going on
and their first performance was to
get up in the neath the full moon
and just sing this absolutely.
If you've ever heard the music
itself in the most lyrical
and beautiful music you
could ever hope to hear
and for me personally it was just
a resolution of the whole thing.
I mean the next day for whatever reason
all of that conflicted been resolved.
We never did actually quite get to the
bottom of what the drug bust in the set up
was all about. But
anyway it all went away.
People went back to to you know the
same feeling of you know tangible.
Peace and cooperation and whatever
that the festival had started with
and in my mind that that
magical concert under
that full moon with the bowels of
bengal will always be one of the things
that for me personally made the
home in the festival worthwhile.
I guess the other one was finally.
Fairly party coming down to sydney in before
he left walking between the two pilots
with the sydney harbour bridge illegally
i might add. While he was doing it.
They were policemen down the bottom
trying to untie the guy guy wires
and i saying well if you do that will
be manslaughter and then saying well.
So this is seen as he comes down is going
straight into a paddy wagon but all
that aside.
He did manage to minister
being the person that he was
that the challenge in coming to australia
was to walk between the violence of the
harbour bridge and that image
went right around the world
and in fact i mean the mad
and chappie feeling to it in a schnorrer
view over the fate of a few weeks
and saying the spirit of nimbin conquers
the spirit of the industrial revolution
and so they were i mean in a way. I i.
I bring out
that story because it illustrates i think
one of the things about an inborn that's
been forgotten in the years in the sense
that nimbin infiltrated in many many
different nimbin for me was never just
never just a place. There's never
just a country town in new south.
House
and it was never just a festival of 10 15000
people gathering for 10 days for minimum
was always an idea and a
movement and a group of friends
and many other things. That.
Grew out of a certain cultural
condition in australia
that was quite unique was
lucky enough to manifest that
and to express it at a time.
And then i think too it rose
and then went again some people
remained physically nimbin and made
that their home other people took
that that and him an experience
or comradery aust or spirit or whatever
you might want to call it took
that back to their universities
or their health food restaurants
or their musical bands or whatever
and i think for some years then there was
a certain kind of recognition of people
who had shared their shared
part of that experience
when they would meet there'd be a certain.
Recognition in a certain common ground
that they'd share this experience it was
really a lot more than just a town i think
over the years it's become something else.
Now i remember that in the
few years after nimbin
and wasn't very respectable i mean because
of all those kind of tabloid press
headlines about the drug raid etc..
It wasn't very respectable and my mother
i mean never never used to tell people
that i'd be above the minimum festival she
would always sort of explain some other
way until the women's weekly started
running to page kind of photo stories on
alternative lifestyles of nimbin
and then my mother suddenly came very
interested in telling the neighbours
and friends that you know that johnny
had been involved in this thing.
So i think it went through many different
changes over the years for a long while i
mean
that the sydney morning herald was running
sort of regular features after nimbin
what. Around the universities
there was this alkaline of.
Discussion of you know after nimbin
what it said something about this the
significance that that the event and
been in the lives of lots of peace.
Ok
but it came then in journalistic terms i
think to represent a rather handy shorthand
for alternatives hippies
drugs all of those things so
that i think now we're nimbin so
dragged out sometimes ance is not a.
Not a barber a b c who are this program
but we're niman is dragged out now it's
quite often dragged out as a shorthand.
First of a certain set of things
which is not very fair to nimbin
or very fair to the things that it but
it represented because as i say i think
that to really try
and add up what niman was to so many
different people would be very hard.
I mean i have lived very closely
through the whole thing
and i couldn't very easily put into words
what neiman was the you know is now.
And once you try and reduce those
things to sort of tabloid simplicity.
You either missed the point of
the point beyond recognition.
But i think the thing that came out of
it for me was that it was a gathering
that brought together a lot of very
creative and important strands
and then out the other end those
same strands went out again
but they went out reinvigorated and
strengthened by a sort of dialogue
and the sort of process
that any man was so in many ways
it was it was what one would hope.
A festival or a celebration is in
the society and for me personally.
That's what i picked up on.
I mean the last 20 years for me has
been not spent being an alternative
society person or farming
or whatever it nimbin the last 20 years
for me is been exploring that potential.
What is the role of celebration. What
is the role of community events.
Leading into what i now do which is events
manager for darling harbour in sydney
running. Hundreds of projects a year
and doing a festival every weekend
and looking back over my life i've
been i've only been if you expect.
Since is that that i've had that that's
that sort of social process that
that was no nothing.
The bicentenary in australia was one quite
very different event very different
involvement very different colouring.
But i think
that you can almost talk about australia
before the bicentenary in australia after
the bicentenary in terms of what
that meant as a bit of a cultural watershed
in terms of australia's identity
and in terms of the way we think
about i mean i think that
and just as it's taken decades to work out
an immanent will take many more i think
it'll take a couple of decades
to work out the basin too near.
I think all the talk now of of
australia becoming a republic
and the increased awareness
of aboriginal culture
and how white australia sits with
it's it's it's it's a regional past
that i think all of those
things are part and parcel and
and that's what i what i what
i mean by celebration i mean
celebration has or has in my mind
always overtones it's about very deep.
Currents and cultural
thinking in the society.
It may appear to be just about lots of
people sort of you know going out on one day
and having a good time
but if it's genuine celebration to
me it's it's a very profound thing
that has all those. Waves of change
and always reflections to it.
It's interesting to think
back and speculate on.
Where we're society's got to
when people don't use the phrase for
example i haven't heard for years.
The phrase counterculture or even
alternative society to match anymore
and i think what's tended to happen
is that a lot of the insights of of
that period have been taken on
board by the way the society.
I mentioned earlier for example that
that in one hundred seventy three to talk
about a whole a hole in the ozone layer
and to talk about the
greenhouse effect that's a.
I mean they're there for
many years they'd been.
And scientists and environmentalists
who were aware of all those things
and you know that certainly will say
were common knowledge but in terms of
that population in general if you talked
about those things you were either mad
or you were complete radical it's been
interesting to see what's happened in the
last 20 years.
I mean society is absorbed so many of those
things they've absorbed the threat more
i think people now realize
that it's not complete madness to
talk about greenhouse effects etc..
It's something that could be very real.
It could be just around the corner and
people of all say are sort of absorbed.
Some of the solutions i mean i think
that. Right across the board.
I think the environment as assumes a place
in people sinking now which is radically
different to that which
it did 20 years ago and
that is reflected as it has
to be in very sort of.
Fire and lifestyle ways in an environment
isn't isn't just about sort of.
The mega picture.
It's about what you do with the
ravishing how you recycle things
and what you do with your life and
if it's not brought in trouble.
I mean i remember leaving leaving
new york on one visit to new york
and this is wonderful piece of graffiti
outside kennedy airport just as i was
leaving new york that said ecology
last fad. And that scared me.
I mean if if if if we do manage to let these
things like ecology in the environment
etc remain just kind of fashionable fading
issues then the future is very bleak
indeed. So i think that.
Society is it has absorbed most of
those things the question i think that
that we're all trying to
resolve is that one some sort.
It's absorbed all those things are there
any solutions you know can we arrive at a
sister. A nibble future and solve some of
those things the dilemmas are enormous.
I mean i think we've got one part of the.
The industrial first world sort of you
know busily now trying to trying to shed
some of those worst excesses
and with the same time we've got many
parts of the third world desperate do you
know to do all that consuming that
there will be always been denied.
So you've got the currents going
in both directions at once
and the problems are enormous at the
same time i think human ingenuity is is
enormous and i mean some of
my heroes from that time were
and i think always will remain the
buckminster fuller's and people like
that who take all that on board and say
look there are. There are solutions.
It's a question of that's
becoming innovative an arf
and thoughtful enough to work that through
and i i don't know i mean i think i
probably see it on a little bit of the
fence with all of
that where we're going to be in another
20 years whether we're going to work some
of those things through or whether we're
going to keep plunging headlong down a.
Took living in i don't think anyone can
say i think we all know how important the
issues are that we know what some
of the choice but it's not simple.
It's tempting to sit back
and say well you know the family argument
if only people would do blah blah blah.
That's not the way it works
it's going to be a sort of.
A long and a slow
and gradual working through so
many of the signs are positive.
That the problem is enormous and.
I don't think it will be in my
lifetime that we reach a resolution of
that i think
that it's something the ball carry well
into the 21st century in another generation
will be grappling with it.
Long before long after i've
suffered off to a more peaceful
existence than where else. Before.
Like. Told.
In terms of how
that sort of celebration theory in
impulse of an indian is has made its way
into the larger population i think it's
it's actually amazing to consider again.
And yes you lived through and remember
accurately the australia of the 50s.
It is very hard to realize the difference
between the looseness and the freedom
and the colour and whatever that exists
in our society. Now that didn't.
20 30 years ago. I mean
even just a member.
When you saw when you saw a
male in a colourful shirt.
It was unusual in you turned
and looked twice now you walk through
any any sort of any shop in town
and the sort of you know that.
About that whole area of design
and whatever's influenced our fashions in
our daily life to an extraordinary extent
and to an extent that's mainly positive
it's also influenced i think very much.
Our ability to celebrate and
and our thoughts on celebration i
think it's it's a looser culture.
One of the things that but that i've
always been deeply involved in is that.
We live in a you know a.
A european or what was a european
cultural outpost in southeast asia
and what we did in that first
century in shriek orders
or whatever was it was simply
import european culture into
australia in the largely indoor
culture that we have of concert halls
and theaters etc.
Is something that was devised in a
european environment and came out of that
and violence suited
that environment you live in a cul climate
of course you want to go indoors.
I think the challenge in australia
is to develop a culture that that
that comes out of the australian environment.
Which is a totally different one.
Where are much warmer subtropical culture
where very much an outdoor cultures over
sort of the sort of cultural
experiences and events
that have always interested
me are outdoor celebrations
and outdoor events for two reasons
first of all i think that sort of.
Is much more explorative of
the australian condition
and it's much more you know
what's unique about australia
and secondly because they can
be larger and more sociable.
I think that those events where people
do that shoulders in the hundreds
and in their thousands are very valuable
events and i don't think i'm alone in
that i think that right
across the stage in society.
There's been a move in that direction.
I mean the whole there's a whole events
and celebrations movement in the
industry in this trailer now
that there wasn't 20 years ago.
I mean it couldn't have been
about antinori 20 years ago
and that's changed i think the way people
react the way one another though at the
way they think again it's
one of these things that.
You've got to take a long term view of
it may ask why why are people wanting
there's experiences.
And how is it changing the nature of
the culture and i think there are pros
and cons to it. I think that increasingly
we exist in a culture where most people.
Don't relate to their neighbours
or even their families.
Perhaps as much as they did.
20 and 30 years ago we tend
to sit in chairs in a room
and spend many hours a day watching this
little square box called television
and we relate to the world fairly much.
Electronically and by the motorcar
and if you go to los angeles
you'll see this taken to extremes
and i think that's produced a civilization
where people just don't touch one
another in flesh and blood
very much the way they used to
when the cultural event of the week was
going out to a movie theater at least
rubbing shoulders in the crowd
or going out to the sea.
Today and i bet it's we do
live in a more kind of.
Technologically isolated and boxed
in sort of society and i think
that one of the responses to
that it's been for people to
want the experience of going out
and being part of a large crowds.
I think
that if we could shoot 50 years into the
future somewhere into the sort of you know
the year 2000.
Whatever and look back on
the 80s and 90s i think
that the the unique images
and the important cultural events will
be those mass people events it's all the
sort of you know the the light of a
concerts and i sent in reason and
that all ships are all of those things i
think say something about this period in
time
and what's unique about the culture of this
period of time i guess i mean i tend to
think about a lot about
that because that's the work i do i'm
involved by choice in creating community
celebrations and whether
that's a celebration for 50
or 200 people are whether that's a celebration
for a hundred thousand people to me
the mechanism the mains the same but
i do observe that that you know
that people seem to want
that experience the fact
that you can get a hundred thousand people
to come out for an australia day at
darling harbour whatever it is says
something about a need for that.
And so i think there's says a lot about
where we're trying to find a tribal society
again. Some of us are
finding it by going off
and living in small groups in alternative
situations some of us are finding it by
living inside the wider
urban based culture
but trying to find ways of reconnecting.
Via celebrations and i'm glad we're doing
it that way because it strikes me that.
Societies only seem to break
down all those boundaries
and work together in a hugely
cooperative way for one of two reasons
that happens in wars with this.
Response to the threat and
it happens in peace time
when there's a cause for celebration.
And i know which one of those
motivations i'd invite other work off.
Right.
If you had to try
and sum up the the careers festival
in the ideals behind i would say
that the first one was probably
the exploration of alternatives.
The feeling that that we were reaching
dead ends and that in the state of.
In a state of crisis such as i think we've
probably been in with so we've been in
for so long that used to it.
Now the site in a state
of environmental crisis
and social crisis in many
ways i think at those times.
The thing that you do is explore a range
of alternatives until you find new ways
and find what works.
So i think in terms of the the spirit of
nimbin the thing which would stand out
for me. Most would be that that one of
exploring alternatives and whether they are.
As i said earlier whether
they were kind of.
Cultural alternatives or or building
alternatives or food alternatives
or healing alternatives it doesn't matter.
My own sort of you know approach
to that was a very very wide one.
There weren't any lines.
I wasn't about this new age
religion or theory or that one.
It was just about exploring alternatives
and was valid to explore them all in the
second one would be in these sound like
funny words now because like i mean that
itself to be an overused so many times
that that the words had to
know what the words now mean.
But there was a very tangible. Spirit
and cooperation and brotherhood.
Togetherness there was an im than that
certainly been fairly unique to me.
I havent experienced it
many times in my life
and ive never experienced it as strongly
as through it and im an experience.
Why that should be so i am not quite
sure but i think it has a lot to do with
when people are working together towards
some sort of common cause and that
that does create a real brotherhood it
could create an intellectual affinity
and it creates a sort of an emotional
empathy in all of those things
that come out in words like peace and love
but actually you know manifest
themselves in situations that work and
and then i guess the.
The third one to me would be a sort
of a cultural cultural dimension
that i think nimbin did
or did find new ways in
terms of australian culture
in many different directions and
by culture i do mean fairly widely
and i'm talking about sort of you know.
Music in theatre in that i'm
also talking much more widely.
I'm talking about the sort of the way
culture manifests itself right across our
lives in sort of you know in in how we
relate how we eat how we dress how we build
our hands. I think that to me it was.
The cultural watershed as in the
way in which i could express it.
It probably was a little
bit the culmination of.
In many ways alignment happened in 73 in
many ways it sort of belongs in the 60s of
some of our actually ticks were.
But in many ways it was kind of
brought i think to to a head
that pace war australian period where
i think that after the war that
that people didn't have much choice but
to put their heads down and rebuild
and it did sort of in a creator.
A very conservative period and i think
niman was a bit of a watershed where
that came to an end and it read a bit
of a way of tested it with the baby.
An all those sort of things
as well read a bit of a way
that i think you can talk about
before nimbin and afternoon
and a low it's very
hard to put into words.
I think that there was a certain sort
of cultural change that around that had
that had to do with the whitlam
government coming to power
and many other layers as
well but i think from around
that point australia
started to see itself.
Both in much more in terms of
an australian culture and what
that meant in terms of you know identity
and identity expressed through films
music books social education thought
and also one that we're still working
through and it may be the year 2000.
Maybe significant our
place in southeast asia
that although our history was out of our.
Are you think altschul
outpaced our reality was
that we were significantly
a part of southeast asia.
And i think that sort of you know from
from that time onwards and that that
but didn't bring that about but
an emblem was riding a wave
that was about those sort of issues
and a very sort of broad cultural
change which will continue on
and my fervent hope is
that we declare republic in australia in
an the first of january of the year 2000.
I think it's suitable time to put
a full stop to that said she
and say ok.
New millennium new vision
new place in the world.
I don't know whether there will
ever be another name in a way
that there needs to the terms of the you
know the nimbin i mean it's it's quite
interesting. I think
that the celebrations of.